>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Paul Ford: Hi.
Welcome back from lunch.
It's good to see everyone.
This is a nice crowd for me.
This is like -- this
feels like home.
Just good data nerds everywhere.
Oh, let's see.
I'm going to start
with a short reading.
It's about two minutes long.
You're going to wonder why
the hell I'm doing this,
and later it will become clear.
It is the raccoon history of New
York City from the perspective
of a disgruntled [inaudible] raccoon
based on New York Times searchers.
We have been here longer
-- I'm a raccoon.
than you have.
We dipped our paws in the
spring on Spring Street.
We climbed the trees in the
forest of lower Manhattan.
We laughed in the moonlight
and ate beautiful dinners
of blackberries and lady bugs.
And you came and you
stayed and you built houses.
Fine. We're small.
We will make room.
You made muffins.
We ate the crumbs.
Everyone was happy.
But not for long because
you wanted coats.
So we went into exile upstate.
For hundreds of years we kept
to ourselves, sneaking garbage
at night, the occasional bed
of lettuce or baked beans
or on a good night baked goods.
Our fur was always in style,
and it was a hard life.
But we lived on our love and our
wits, and then in the 1970's,
there was a fur boom, and I was
sure that was the end of us.
But thank God, finally,
finally, we went out of fashion.
And people began to realize
that we the raccoons
had a right to be there.
They stood up for us.
In 1982, a woman named -- in 1982,
a meaning was held in Scarsdale.
Have we no decency in this town?
Asked a lady named Rita.
Raccoons are bright,
lovable creatures.
Do we want our children to
walk by their carcasses?
No, Rita, we don't.
Do you see what was happening?
We weren't just getting
into your garbage.
We were getting into your hearts.
Word on rabies.
Now, listen, I'm first to admit
that rabies is a problem
in our community.
Let me tell you a story.
It was 1998 in Woodstock, New York.
Lots of places sell baked goods
there, great town, very open-minded.
And we thought we could
trust the humans.
So this one raccoon, a little
guy, had a good thing going
with a woman named Barbara.
She gave him treats.
It was a backyard thing,
and you know how this goes.
But it wasn't enough for Barbara.
One day she trapped
him and took him.
It's tough to talk about this.
Took him to the local daycare
where she introduced this tiny
little raccoon to all the children,
and the raccoon cuddled with
everyone, 14 toddlers, ten adults.
Beautiful, right?
But when it turned out that
all 24 humans had been exposed
to rabies, who was blamed?
Not Barbara.
Who was shot in cold blood and
buried by Barbara's husband?
Not Barbara.
Who had his little body dug up
by the Department of Health?
Not Barbara.
Let me tell you.
The name they gave that
raccoon, are you ready?
The name the humans gave that
raccoon in 1998 was Spartacus.
That's the truth.
The leader of the slave revolt.
You can read it on the
article in the paper of record.
Who's to blame here?
The raccoon doing its best or the
society that only accepts cuteness?
Now look, we always wanted
to come back to the city.
This is our home.
In 1984, a single raccoon
sighting in midtown was enough
to make the New York Times.
Let me ask you.
If you don't want raccoons,
why would you build an ornamental
gold fish pond on 51st Street?
By 2002, we'd made it
to the Bronx for real,
and over the last 15
years, we found our way back
to the city to all the burrows.
Today you'll find us everywhere, and
we've actually taken over Brooklyn.
We've returned.
Our trees and streams are gone, but
we make the best of what's there.
And you call this [inaudible]
is doubly insulting.
Let me take the second word first.
Panda is overrated.
Their ecological niche
is five inches wide,
and if you don't serve them
fresh bamboo prepared just
so they fall over and die.
Imagine a panda finding its
way down the FDR to midtown.
But also that first word, trash.
Let me ask is it so wrong that
we want what you throw away,
your spare [inaudible] dollops,
your blue sky bakery muffin chunks?
I live from your [inaudible]
leavings.
Your trash is my gold.
Why not treasure Panda?
And remember, we're not your guests.
You are the guests of the raccoons.
So the reason for that will
become clear momentarily.
We got through the raccoon
portion of the talk.
And now I'm going to
make some observations
about a life spent lived
between media and archives
and then do a very brief
software demo like a minute.
And then issue some recommendations
to the assembled audience
because it's not often that
I get you all here together,
and I'm kind of excited to tell you
what I need and ask for your help.
So in 2006, 2005, I was a
writer, and I was doing okay,
and I got a job at Harpers
Magazine in charge of their website.
I was also kind of a programmer,
just one of those people
who did a couple of different
things kind of poorly.
And Harpers being cheap was
like, "Well, this will do."
And brought me on.
And I'll get -- a good
example of what it was
like to work there was the publisher
took me aside, and I was like,
"I think we should put some articles
from the magazine on the internet,"
and his response was, "You're
like McNamara getting me further
into the Vietnam of
the world wide web,"
which literally tells you everything
you need to know, and so after --
there wasn't any Wikipedia,
so I just had to make
due with that analogy.
And -- but given no money, given
lots of time, and given sort
of the resources at hand, I realized
this magazine had gone back to 1850,
and also there was this sort
of white elephant bibliography
that they built.
They built it during the days
when they were going to make it
and then sell terminals to research
libraries for tens of thousands
of dollars a year so that
people could walk to the stacks
and go get the magazines off
the stacks going back to 1850,
and everything was
beautiful and started
with [inaudible] subject
headings and on and on.
And, of course, it had gone terribly
over schedule and so they started
in '89 or '90 and now it was '95 and
nobody -- everybody wanted pictures.
So now ten years later, I show up
and I'm like, this thing's great.
Let's put some pictures with it.
And they said, "Great.
We'll give you 18 grand, and
that includes your scanner."
So I bought -- I did
some experiments.
I bought a Fujitsu 5750C,
and I scanned the hell
out of that archive.
Making of America had gone 1850 to
1900 out of Cornell and other places
so I traded them a hard drive
with Harpers up to 1923,
up to the public domain line and
gave them some bibliographic data.
They gave me -- it was just this
insane horse trading with no money
in which I was doing
all the programming,
all the scanning or
most of the scanning.
I had a high school
student who was terrible.
Actually, I should
have done all of it.
And -- in the 70's, there's like
all these little [inaudible] cut
from the spine because he
wasn't paying attention.
Anyway, got it down to like
seven cents a page, put it up
and then suddenly everybody
was really nice to me.
And they had been yelling
at me before.
I was a cost center.
But it turns out is that it's
very expensive to get someone
to subscribe to a magazine,
often 20, 30, up to 100 bucks
to get somebody to
subscribe to a magazine
that they might pay $20 for.
And the reason that it's
worth it to pay that is
because advertising is what
really funds the publication.
And so what I had done all of a
sudden, all these subscriptions came
in because people like archives.
They don't like them -- they
like subscribing but the idea
of getting everything back
to 1850 was very motivating.
And so suddenly instead of
having to spend 35 bucks,
we were getting these
digital subscribers
who were just showing up.
And they were really nice to
me for a couple of months.
They were really happy I was there
because I wasn't making the money
with the archive, but
I was saving the money.
And the reason you need to
keep your circulation up is
that advertisers buy by number, and
it's audited so it's like if you're
at a quarter million, you have to
spend all the money in the world
to keep at a quarter million or
your whole business model implodes.
So that's one big interaction
between archives and the media
that I can share with you.
Also, the whole time I was ashamed
because I would go to the Library
of Congress website and other sites
which had standards for scanning,
and it would be like only 96 bit
uncompressed [inaudible] were
acceptable ever.
I had one -- a couple hard drives
and no money, and I was like --
I just made a decision
that if I can see the grain
of the paper, that that was okay.
But no one backed me up on that.
And so I built this archive that
was good that ended up being resold
to lots of university libraries.
It was fine, but the
whole time I did it I was
like I don't know what the
right angle of pages is,
and I don't know what the tolerances
truly are because with the standards
that are published
are incredibly high.
They're just -- they're not intended
for amateurs with no budgets,
but that was the real world I
was in to get this asset online.
Also, I scored a whole copy of
the archive from Bennington.
Somebody drove down from Vermont
and Toyota and just gave me all
of Harpers because they
wanted digital access.
So that's how that got done, right?
It's a completely no
grant, no process,
no good standards, no
clear understanding.
And yet it got done.
Also, once I got it out there,
people immediately came in
and started to threaten lawsuits.
The number one job of an editor
is not to make things beautiful
or to make the prose great.
It's to avoid litigation.
Putting all these things online
meant that people who had forgotten
about that unfortunate incident
in 1995 suddenly were back
and were angry that it had found
its way onto the web again.
So just something worth noting.
My microphone is falling off
so we'll see how it goes.
And then I left there, worked
for a big consulting --
or small media consulting
firm that gave me lots
of access to big media companies.
I built a version of Gourmet
Magazine for the iPad,
which many things aside, it was
based on archives from Gourmet.
And I learned -- I think it was
very important that I will continue
to talk about which is asset panic.
Unless you have the
assets in your hand
and you can't believe how many
people tell you no worries.
I'm going to go get you a hard
drive with all that stuff.
Don't worry.
Fine. And like four months goes by,
they're like actually there's
12 lawyers involved now.
I don't know how the
hell it happened.
Both things increase risk
in an organization and API's
and archives are territories.
People are very fiercely
dependent, defendant around them
and so I learned to
navigate and deal with that.
That's another reality
in this world.
So that's my advice to
anyone if you ever end
up in the private sector
working on archives, panic.
Just constantly frequently
never stop panicking
until you have full control over
all the assets and have them
in the digital form
that you can manipulate.
Then as mentioned in my
intro very graciously,
I wrote this thing a couple of
years ago called what is code
for Bloomberg Business Week,
and they basically said, here,
take the whole issue
of the magazine.
And I write about code, do anything
you want, go crazy, have fun.
And it was terrifying.
They were literally like hey, we're
going to give you the whole issue,
and I went and hid under a
blanket, and my wife laughed at me,
and I moaned because I knew that
everyone was going to yell at me.
There's no way you'd
do something like this
and programmers don't
come scream at you.
But the key thing is
that we talk about this,
and we talk about me,
the writer, I did it.
A hundred people worked on this
at least, and even more so --
I want to come back to this point --
but there was a [inaudible]
repository.
So after it was published,
it went out
and people continued to correct it.
So probably 200 people had
their hands on this thing,
and all of it -- some of their
work is tracked, some of it isn't.
But what we just do
culturally is just like, oh,
Paul Ford wrote this thing,
which is great for me.
I love it.
Seriously, like it's fantastic.
My ego is constantly gratified.
But it's gratified based on lies.
So I live with it.
I live with it, and I do okay.
But the writing process
is stochastic.
It's not this nice, clear delineated
thing where there's versions and --
it's just crap flying everywhere,
and everyone's putting stuff off
until the last minute and nobody
knows what the hell is going on.
Last little stage of my life, I
decided I would start a business
with my -- with the cofounder, a
guy named Rich Ziotti, and it was --
we're building just --
we're digital products.
We build apps and websites
in New York City,
and I was like, "This is it.
Done with archives for awhile,
probably done with
the cultural sector.
Let's make a little money
and go work for banks."
But they find you.
You can't get away.
Archives can't be escaped.
I can't even talk about
half the work.
A big NGO came.
I ended up -- I'm like on the phone
for an hour and a half talking
with Nara, and Nara
loves conference calls.
I don't know if you've ever
had that experience, but whew.
So a lot of conference calls, a
lot of like what asset goes here
and what asset goes there.
And so no matter what you
do, you deal with archives.
And what I realized is that
all our software problems,
kind of our legacy
problems and archive is kind
of a nice way to say legacy.
The cultural sector dealing with
big archives is actually not
that different from
going to some company,
and they have five terabytes
of information and user records
and all kinds of things that
they need to make sense of.
So in some ways there, the
problems base is kind of similar.
So I'm going to do a quick
software demo as I now try
to take everything I just
told you and synthesize it.
A couple of more things to know.
I mean, I love timelines.
Timelines are great.
They're beautiful.
Many of the speakers have
talked about timelines.
I'm going to tell you
something about timelines.
This one's great.
Oh yeah, that one's from
the Washington Post.
This is -- where we go --
oh boy, everything's gone
-- nothing's going my way.
I'm going to go backwards .
There we go.
So timelines are great.
Timelines are terrible
interfaces by the way.
There we go.
This is all humanity.
Timelines always seem like a
good idea, and I'm not like five
or six years in and built a bunch.
They never actually solve a
problem, but they look cool.
Sometimes they kind of do.
It hurts, it really stings.
I want to believe in timelines
so bad, so bad, but I can't.
[Inaudible] three years
late on a book.
This is kind of the confession part.
I just want to share this with
you because why would a guy
who has a software company and is
a writer go and build software?
Because it's because he
doesn't want to write something.
These are all the things
I've done to avoid the book.
I agreed to give this talk, that's
one, create experimental websites,
learn two new computer languages,
rented an office, a
lot of coffee stuff.
I got into coffee,
got out of coffee,
got some cushions,
some nice cushions.
I bought a whiteboard.
I wrote software to manage my
anxiety about writing the book.
I wrote that business week piece.
That's actually kind of what's
supposed to be from the book
but then I did that instead.
A lot of medium posts,
cofounded a company.
But there's one in here I wrote,
and then abandoned this book writing
because when you're
supposed to write a book,
the first thing you do is
write a CMS to manage the book.
So I did this like
three or four years ago.
I wrote the CMS, and I kind of got
30, 40, 50 percent of the way there,
and I was like eh, and
then I gave up on that.
So I had like two things.
[Inaudible] procrastination.
It's actually really interesting
because then you're like do I have
to -- do I just stop and finish the
book or should I back out from --
I'm like now so far in
so I clean the office
and then finish the CMS
and then write the book.
So it turns out I remained
blocked, and I'm still blocked.
I'm still kind of working
through that.
There's a third thing that
goes into the software demo
which is the media is
having a really bad time.
Nobody trusts it.
It's -- 72 percent of people kind
of trust national news org --
but only 20 percent trust it a lot.
I mean, you saw Rachel here earlier.
She's working hard.
She's getting a lot of
statistics all lined up and working
with journalists to try
to get things as factual
as possible for the New York Times.
The people who work in that
field are very disciplined
and very serious, and it sucks
but the world doesn't trust them.
It's sad and it's tough
and it's bad marketing,
and it's bad politics,
and it's a situation.
And then also -- sorry to go
back to The Times, but editors
and copywriters and fact checkers
are getting laid off everywhere.
That's just a reality.
It's been reality for
five, ten years now.
There's just less and less money
for them, less and less money
for content production
and so they're going
and then there's a huge discussion
around fake news, and that is --
I'm not going to recapitulate.
You're all living it.
But there's this sense
of news being arbitrary
and journalism being arbitrary.
And writers, in my opinion, are
learning less and less good practice
because they have fewer and fewer
people to keep an eye on them.
And so my solution to this was
to build a timeline
for which I apologize.
And it has all the
regular timeline things.
You give it events and the
events have dates stamped on them
and it arranges them and
then here's a little video
of those things moving around.
And you can click on the date and
zoom out and see different contexts
and this is all powered by an API
with a nice Java script front end.
I knew as I was doing this that
timelines aren't the answer,
but I couldn't help myself.
These are all events from
Wikipedia, events from all over.
And all kinds of different sources.
And so I've gone out to the
1800's and zoomed back in
and then underneath all that,
what you can do is just sort
of bookmark the event and they
kind of go into this pile of stuff
on the right and then you
add notes to the bookmarks,
and that turns into an essay.
So what's nice about that is you're
keeping your sources connected
to the things that you're
writing and then you can kind
of rearrange these
little blocks of text.
It looks like it might
be easy or not easy.
It's actually kind of
a great way to write.
If you are like me and
you're getting older
and you don't trust your memory
as much and you can't count
on fact checkers in the
way that you're used to,
it keeps everything you do
connected to what you're writing.
And so some of those
cultural problems
that are emerging are
very much on my mind.
And I feel that a lot
of the software --
we built CMS's at my company.
I built more CMS's than I'd
like to admit in my life.
You give people a text
box, and then you move on.
And I feel that the text
boxes need to get smarter.
They need to do more work.
And so here's an example of
how I wrote that raccoon piece.
I imported a ton of New York
Times and other search results,
some of the Cooper
Hewitt Collection,
which actually didn't have a lot
of raccoon based information
but still was cool.
Search for raccoon and it made a
timeline as a result, looked around,
read some raccoon articles
and then started
to write factually based
slightly funny raccoon prose.
Okay, so that piece exists
because I built my system,
and I wanted to test it out.
So that's just something
to think about.
There's some continuity there.
So anyway, [inaudible].
Here's what I have really learned
from building that and doing that.
I want to get to about a terabyte
of metadata in that thing.
It's probably like 50,
100 megabytes right now.
There's a lot of -- maybe a
little more if you count images.
And I want to get as much
cultural information in as events
as I possibly can over
the next say year or so.
I want to be clear, what I showed
you, it's a personal side project.
I built that thing.
I'm using it to write.
It actually has really helped
unblock me on the book.
And because it turns out it's a
great quote from Joyce Carroll
that said, "Writer's block is
related to the writer's sense
of their own fraudulence."
And what this does is it keeps
you from feeling like a fraud.
You're like all right,
there's an event.
I wrote a little note about it.
I wrote another note.
And suddenly you're
writing an essay,
and that is actually very good at
taking away the block that you get
when you have a pile
of books on one side
and a blank screen on the other.
So this is what the world
looks like a little bit
around cultural archives that
are open and can be imported.
You've got -- I won't even explain
this chart because you all live it.
But I've been through all of it.
I love XML.
I love XSLT.
I love RDF.
I love CSV.
I love UTF8 data.
I don't love web services and
so -- but I'm mixed on mets.
But there's [inaudible].
This is how stuff comes out.
This is what you get today,
and it's really freaking hard
to work with, all of it.
And I've worked with all of it, and
I'm good at working with all of it.
I'm like 20 years in.
I photocopied the SGML ISO
standard at a college library
after getting it through [inaudible]
all 900 pages of it because I saw it
as wonderful secret lure when
I was 20 years old, which is --
that doesn't leave the
room, but really --
but I mean, I love this stuff,
but it's also just kind
of increasingly hard.
It's intractable to work with when
you're trying to really explore
and understand the data set or
import it in bulk into another view.
And so I've been -- I'll talk
through some of the ones I looked
at -- Cooper Hewitt, amazing,
[inaudible] links to
images, fantastic.
Actually kind of hard because it's
zillions of files, very hard --
you have to import it somewhere
and then search through it.
Met, giant CSV file,
hard to work with.
Doesn't directly link to images.
It has a sort of interstitial ID.
It's so -- but I need pictures.
I love pictures.
Everyone who works in media needs
pictures to make their thing useful.
My timeline kind of sucks
and isn't exciting for me
to use unless it has pictures.
So then am I spidering
every webpage in order
to figure out what the image is?
All that sort of stuff comes
up because the CSV
doesn't include images.
This is me by the way
criticizing the comments,
just me saying hey thanks
for all the incredible things
you've given me for free
and you're really hard work.
Let me tell you why I hate it.
I'm mindful of that.
The stuff is a gift.
This API is again wonderful
and terrible.
Kind of great to work with,
slow just doesn't always --
it's hard to know where you are.
This thing is horrible.
When you get into the
XML in this bad boy,
it is just an endless nightmare of
pain, and there's no way around it.
Wikipedia is hard to
work with the raw data.
There's [inaudible].
There's all these other -- I mean,
there's so many projects to deal
with the fact that Wikipedia
data is tough to work
with that I can't even listen.
25 million mark records,
which thanks and also thanks.
Right? They're great, and I
started messing around with them.
I got [inaudible].
I started fooling around and
doing everything I could,
but they're hard to work with.
They're from a specific world.
Gorgeous API.
[Inaudible] actually has one of the
nicest designed comment driving,
public API's I've ever seen.
Hierarchy is incredibly clear.
I want to spider the
whole damn thing
and just know everything that's in
there, and there's no simple way
to do that aside from writing
a web spider and then sort
of mapping it to my schema.
And so I think there's this tension
going on between archive and access
with how things are
actually working,
and I think that we've cut things
up like right now I think the
consensus is a great open API
is enough.
For God's sake, it is,
it's a wonderful thing.
But I'm going to mention something
that we don't like to talk
about very much in our community
which is relational databases
in SQL, which are everywhere.
This is the data language
of the universe.
This is how people store
and retrieve data is
through SQL databases.
And this little guy, SQLite
is entirely public domain.
It's on all of your phones.
It's on Android.
It's on IOS.
It's built in everywhere.
It comes as part of Python.
It is 150K SQL database that kind of
runs the world and it's so powerful
and unassuming that nobody
really talks about it.
But if you could start putting all
of your data into SQL Lite databases
and making those available,
then I could download them,
and I could start searching
and exploring it without having
to put it anywhere in five seconds.
I could start hacking and
messing with public [inaudible]
in the time it took to
download because once you get in
and you type SQL Lite
database, you're good to go.
You can even turn on full
text search, public domain,
[inaudible] UTF8 or
UTF16 by default, etc.,
etc. It actually hits all the sweet
spots that we usually talk about.
It just doesn't talk
about them in the way
that we usually talk about them.
Also, if you could
make them torrentable,
my God that would be great.
I know that may be really
hard for an organization,
a large cultural organization.
You could just take
your SQL Lite file --
and by the way, I'm not
saying get rid of your API.
I'm not saying get
rid of your CSV's.
I'm just saying do this other thing,
too, or suggest to someone else even
like me to go and do it for you.
If you point to the thing, if you
say like, "Hey, we didn't do this,"
but if you want to
torrent everything
as a SQL Lite database,
go it's over here.
That's fantastic.
A little bit of institutional
[inaudible] to say that's
at least semiofficial is a
really, really powerful signal.
I can't tell you enough
because there's all these --
Wikipedia is a great example.
There's eight million extracting
data from Wikipedia projects.
None of them are particularly
blessed.
I guess there's like semantic
media [inaudible] and a few others
that have more involvement
with the foundation.
But you just don't
know where to start.
If I could just get this, if I
can click download the torrent,
I will start messing with and
incorporating your corporate
into my historical writing tool
within hours, and I will make sure
that every single one of those
boxes has a clear link back
for accreditation back
to your organization.
I will absolutely want to do that.
If you give me an API or a CSV,
you've added sometimes months
of work to that process.
So again, supplement, not replace.
I'm not asking people to replace
what they are with this formula,
but some sort of comments were met
that I could immediately start
manipulating would be fantastic.
Leave the original record,
even put it into SQL Lite.
You don't have to throw
away to the past.
I know that's really
hard to do culturally
to throw away old records.
Don't. Just leave them there.
Assume storage is free.
Assume bandwidth is free.
I can download -- I have a ten
terabyte drive at home to work with.
I spent like $1000 on a
really, really powerful machine.
And I have very fast internet, and
that's just me at home in Brooklyn.
It's not -- that's the entirety
of money invested into
[inaudible] so far.
And also images.
Anything you can do to be
visual with your corporate --
it makes it easier for
me to hack with, explore
and put them into other context.
It's such a powerful signal.
And again yeah, if you
can't do, just point,
just say like hey, this looks legit.
We're happy that they
put in this SQL Lite.
Good job. Because I know that
culturally it can be hard
to do new things with your data.
So that's my big ask.
Going back to where we
were, I think there are sort
of two main fallacies of archives.
The publishers believe they're free
content and that you can just sort
of use them over and over again
and find value in the past
that can be easily exposed.
It can't, not without a lot of human
work to add context and meaning
which is what everyone who has been
up here today has essentially
emphasized.
It's an unbelievable amount of
labor to get value and meaning
and news out of archives.
I tried to correct the publishers
on this, and they get really sad.
They're like, "We want
to build an archive
of our wonderful publication."
And I'm like, "Well, let me
tell you what that will take,"
and then like ten minutes later,
they ask me to leave the room.
The archivist's fallacy
is a little bit
that news is an archive
waiting to happen.
That's not real either.
There's all sorts of
things that are going
on around how media is produced.
And so what I'm trying
to do here is just see
if software can help
resolve that gap
and the number one guinea pig
right now for me is me as a writer
and journalist, supposed to be
doing -- well, that's all right.
Supposed to be doing more work
for business week right now
and of course I'm procrastinating
on that, too.
But I am using the tool,
and it's very productive.
I'm going to try to
open it really soon.
I'm just a little nervous
about API security.
But -- and pretty soon I'll have
probably a couple million events
on it.
So -- but I think that there's an
opportunity for things like this,
and this is just a hypothesis.
I don't -- this is not
[inaudible] this product.
This is something I really
wanted to see in the world,
and I wanted to resolve some
of my own anxiety about facts
and sort of what archives can do.
But I think there's -- just
watching the talks today,
there's been 20 different angles
on this exact same situation.
So -- but I could really
use the help in just sort
of easily importable data.
I have lots of ideas for what
you can do with your date
and time fields including ones
that are 20 years old in mark
and have lots of [inaudible]
characters
in them and are pretty whacky.
I totally can help you.
Just let me know.
I have a strategy.
So that's where I'm at, and I
just wanted to show that to you.
Thank you all very much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress .
Visit us at loc.gov.